「ゆびすま」
地域によっては「いっせーのーで」
「せっさーん」
「ちっちーの」
「チッチッチッチ バリチッチ」
などと呼ばれているゲームがある。
指で何人とでも遊べるゲーム、実にルールは簡単である。
まず、両手をグーにして、親指が見えるように前に構える。
ゲーム開始。
順番を決め、その順に、
指スマ?○○！(数字)
を、言う。
そのタイミングでみんなで親指をあげる。
言った数と親指の数が合えば、片手を下げる。
両手を下げられた人の勝ち。実に簡単なゲームである。
このゲーム、大人数でやると・・・どうなるのだろうか・・・
ここに一人の男が・・・挑戦しようとしていた・・・
こんにちは。Dr.　はじめだ。
ここ恥ずかしいなぁ
皆さんはゆびすまゲームというゲームを御存じでしょうか？
いろんなよびかたがあるみたいで
１　2の
いせいのーで
いせっせの
チッチッチッチ バリチッチ？
せっさん
タコタコ
ルンルン
スパルタ～～ン
ギンギラギンノ
これホントにやってるのかな？
まあ「ゆびすま」と呼んでます
このゲーム
今回は１００人の方にちょっと集まっていただいて
これから１００人でゆびすまゲームをして
何回目で　ピタッと
そろえるのかもう１回でも
揃ったらクリアということで
懸賞的な実験動画になっております。
咳
ご飯粒出ました！
一人ずつ、ゆびすま、ゆびすま
って言ったら終わらないと思うので
僕だけが数字を言ってて
何回目に終わるかをちょっと検証してみよう思います
ではいこう
えーーー、今回お集まりいただいたえっと企画何ですけど・・も
この約１００名の皆さんで
いつ
ゆびすまが
集まってる人）　　笑い
ゆびすまが終わるかをちょっと検証したいと思いまして
本日は皆様でちょっとゆびすまゲームをやっていきたいと思います
よろしくお願いします！！
じゃあ皆様よろしくお願いします
ゆびすま
134！！
なるほどなるほど
ありがとうございます
では集計のほうよろしくお願いします
結果が出ました
はじめしゃちょー　134
結果　（ドラムロール）
100・・
8（108）でございます
う~~~わ～～～
何とも言えないっすね
では２回目行きます
ゆびすま・・・
うん…いい上げぐわいだな
では集計のほうよろしくお願いします
結果が出ました
はじめしゃちょー
結果　（ドラムロール）
うわ～～～まじか！！！！
そっちか～～
ゆびすま・・・
結果
あはは　なるほどなるほどそういうことか！！
なんだ　100　100付近ですね狙いは
ゆびすま・・・
結果
え～～～まじっすか！！！
うわ～～～まじか！！
じゃぁ、もう皆さん行きますよ頑張っていきましょう
ゆびすま～～
結果
あ～～～
ゆびすま～～
結果
お～～～～
ゆびすま～～
いいよいいと思います
集計お願いします
結果が出ました
結果は
こう言う空気なっちゃうんですよね
ゆびすま～～
結果
100・・・
12（112）
あ～～～～～おしいな～～
ゆびすま～～
結果
100・・・
あ～～～ちょっと近づきましたね
集まった人）　・・・
はい。
次１０回目です
ゆびすま～～
パッと見いいと思います
では集計のほうよろしくお願いします
結果が出ました！！
はい！
はじめしゃちょー
結果は
１１１　！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
え！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
マジで！！
よしゃ～～～～
まじですか？！やった！！
なんか